6-Mete English from BBCLearningEnglish.com
Hello, this is 6-Minute English from BBC Learning English. I'm Neil.
And I'm Beth. In this programme, we're discussing the positives and negatives of social media
in the lives of young people. And this is a really trending topic at the moment
because of what's happening in Australia, where a new law to limit under 16-year-olds access
to social media is being debated. Neil, tell me one good thing and one bad thing about having
social media in your life. Well, one good thing is it means I can see what friends are doing
who live far away. And one bad thing is it's really addictive and a massive waste of time.
Well, it's interesting to hear a man's perspective, Neil, because when it comes to issues like
cyberbullying, it's often young women who are most affected. So soon we'll be hearing from women
in different countries about their online experiences. And remember, you can find all the vocabulary
and a worksheet on our website, BBCLearningEnglish.com. But first, I have a question for you, Beth.
In 2024, which was the most regularly used social media platform in the world?
Was it A, Facebook, B, Instagram or C, TikTok? Oh, I'm going to say TikTok.
Well, we'll find out the answer at the end of the programme. Now let's start with the positive
side of social media. As a politics student at Oklahoma University, 21-year-old Haley Hurst
campaigned in the 2024 US presidential election. Here she explains one benefit of social media
to BBC World Service programme Pick of the World. I do think social media has played a
huge role in educating young voters on different policies and different people who are running.
I know Trump has recently said that he has a soft spot in his heart for TikTok. With the growth
of social media, it has sparked a lot more debate. I think my generation two has seen so many
dramatic things happen. Haley thinks one good thing about social media is that it sparks debates
and conversations. It causes debates to start. She comments that Donald Trump is a fan of social media
by saying he has a soft spot for TikTok. If you have a soft spot for something or someone,
you feel affectionate and fond of it. You like it a lot. But of course, that's not the whole story.
Increasingly, young women are reporting the negative impact social media is making on their
lives and the pressure they feel to appear perfect online, especially from men. Manvi Sharma,
age 28, is a business woman and model with a large Instagram following who lives in Delhi, India.
And Kemi Adyemi is a 26-year-old travel blogger from Lagos in Nigeria. Both young women
discuss these social media worries with BBC World Service Programme. Pick of the world.
Don't you to shrink yourself so that they can be the bigger person. They get to listen to what
they're afraid say about you, what their family says about you, and they're not able to stand
up for you to say, oh, I know this person. I believe she's not doing these things for all that
reasons. Manvi thinks some men are intimidated by her popularity on Instagram. Intimidated means
to feel frightened or nervous because you lack confidence. She feels people gossip about her
posts and photos using expressions like, oh my gosh, and oh my god, to express their shock or surprise.
And Kemi agrees. She says that on social media, some people want her to shrink herself,
a phrase meaning that you underuse your full potential in order to avoid making people feel
uncomfortable or to fit in. When she's bullied online, Kemi says that these people don't stand
up for her. To stand up for someone means to defend or support someone who's being criticised
or bullied. And I think it's time you reveal the answer to your question, Neil.
I asked which was the most regularly used social media platform in the world in 2024. Facebook,
Instagram or TikTok. What did you say, Beth? TikTok. I'm afraid you're wrong. It's Facebook
with over three billion regular users. Okay, let's recap the vocabulary we've learned in this program
starting with the verb spark, meaning to cause something such as a debate or argument to start
happening. If you have a soft spot for someone, you feel affection for them. You like them very much.
To be intimidated means to feel frightened or nervous because you lack confidence in a situation.
The expressions, oh my gosh and oh my god, are exclamations of strong feelings like shock,
surprise, anger or disbelief. If you shrink yourself, you make yourself smaller and don't use
your full potential in order to make others feel comfortable or to fit in with them.
And finally, to stand up for someone means to be vocal in defending a person who is being
bullied. Once again, our time is up, but if you're ready for more, head over to the BBC Learning
English website to try the worksheet with a quiz for this program. See you there soon. Goodbye.